the polls are now closed across the
United Kingdom where voters weighed in
on whether Britain should in fact exit
the European Union YouGov online survey
which asked UK citizens how they voted
today was just released it shows 52
percent voted remain while 48 percent
voted leave this is just one poll of
course and it's also an online poll and
these aren't real official results so
you should take it all with a big pinch
of salt here to talk with us about that
brag is it referendum again for the
second time in just a few days bloomberg
editor-in-chief John Nichols way and
much more pleasingly
bonny Quinn I think of Bloomberg Markets
great to see you guys both here you just
said that the word of the day today
bonnie is a cemetry how so well
basically for markets it's an asymmetric
outcome in the sense that if it does
happen to become leave vote which could
still very much happen we've just only
seen the polls closed so we have no idea
no matter what the politicians are
saying what's actually going to be the
outcome then it would be a very
asymmetric decision for markets so the
downside would be probably tremendous
because we've seen sterling rally about
ten big figures ten cents in the last
seven sessions that would probably all
be erased and you'd see a lot of market
turmoil asymmetric also in the sense of
you know politically asymmetric because
if you vote to leave you're gone it's
sayonara and if you vote if you'd vote
to stay you can still leave in the
future that's entirely true and actually
I think that fall in Sterling would be
much higher because most people thought
it would have a 15% fall so maybe
another kind of 10 20 cents on top of
that it would be a huge thing and
currency traders are sitting out there
waiting in sort of mild terror in case
this happens people that people are
sleeping in their offices it's very
similar to you very similar to how we
are at Bloomberg every day do you think
the financial markets implications of
this will be really bad if it turns out
the leap happens yes how about straight
forward you would II would expect you'd
expect the pound to go down by 20 X
cents probably more than that it's one
it's just under 150 at the moment some
people say that if leave were to happen
and if people are given numbers like 115
to the dollar in that that's a huge
seismic change it probably wouldn't be
that far people talk about 130
but even that in terms of the place
where millions are bet Billy
the bet on just a few kind of dimes
difference that's a huge deal
many reasons why it would weaken as well
not only because of the short-term
speculation you know the bearish bets on
sterling but also because longer term
you're talking about huge implications
for British trade British headquartered
companies with subsidiaries in Europe
what would be the regulations for them
would they move their headquarters
column Kelleher of Morgan Stanley was
just one who told Newberg two days ago
that of course they move their
headquarters to Dublin or to Frankfurt
he hadn't decided yet